the John Wick franchise is thinking it's
back with a continental which sees a
young Winston seizing power in 1970s New
York there's some familiar faces an
iconic car and guns lots of guns here's
what you may have missed in the first
trailer
well what are you waiting for
I haven't finished my drink
the first teaser for the Continental
focused primarily on reassuring John
Wick fans that the style tone and action
they've come to expect will be present
in the franchises for spin-off series
but the latest trailer gives us some
insight into the story as well it opens
with Winston Scott spending the night
with a woman who seems to be uninvolved
in the Underworld of Assassins if that's
the case it's extraordinary because
audiences have rarely seen anyone in the
Assassin's Guild interact with citizens
outside of their dark world but the key
takeaway is at Winston at the start of
the series appears to be outside the
table as well at least until his brother
Frankie finds himself in the crosshairs
of the ruling class though there will
likely be more twists and turns to the
plot it's reasonable to theorize that
Winston will start this journey trying
to bring his brother in peacefully to
get the high table off their backs once
that's done he'll seek Justice against
the table and launch an assault on the
continental and finally come to be its
new manager the fans speculated about
how big his role would be Mel Gibson is
very much in the series and from the
looks of the new trailer he's going to
be playing a major role we also learn a
bit more about Gibson's character Cormac
who appears to be the show's Central
antagonist the trailer makes it look
like Cormac is responsible for dragging
Winston Scott back underneath the high
table in order to bring his brother
Frankie in for judgment he looks as if
Cormac will serve as the New York
Continental Hotel manager at the start
of the series which almost certainly
means Winston will unseat him before the
last bullet is fired as Cormac reveals
in the trailer what incites Young
Winston's involvement in the show is the
fact that his brother Frankie stole an
unnamed important item from the hotel
cormack threatens bad things happening
to both Winston and his brother if he's
unable to track down Frankie and return
the stolen item when Frankie first
appears with his brother in the trailer
he's essentially warning Winston away in
response Winston affirms that their
brothers before plotting how they can
strike burst against the Continental
later through voiceover he says this is
more than vengeance
Justice
this line implies that there's more to
the conflict than simply returning what
Frankie stole it's clear that the plots
of the Continental hinges on a Betrayal
on the surface it appears that Winston
betrays cormack when he doesn't
apprehend Frankie Winston's line also
suggests that Frankie's actions might be
justified hence Winston joining the
fight against a continental on his
brother's side rather than continuing to
work for Cormac
in John Wick's World actions speak
louder than words but every so often a
character utters a line that hits very
hard one of the most memorable quotes
comes from the Baba Yaga himself and it
didn't even originate from the franchise
in John Wick chapter 3 Winston asks his
besieged friend what he needs to respond
to the looming threat to the high table
Jon responds simply
under the circumstances your privileges
are reinstated immediately what do you
need
guns
lots of guns this line is a callback to
one of Keanu Reeves's other iconic
characters Neo from The Matrix trilogy
in the first movie of the series Neo
utters the line when tank asks what he
needs to infiltrate the stronghold where
Morpheus is being held guns
lots of guns now it's a case of history
repeating itself as a continental teaser
sees Winston Dragon what looks to be Yan
to an unmarked doorstep and making the
very same request we need guns
lots of guns while the preview suggests
that Winston has always been the Dapper
gentleman with the lover cravats this
may be one of the rare instances where
he gets his hands dirty
in the collection of memorable lines
from the John Wick franchise a close
runner-up to Jon's request for guns is
Ian mcshane's super smooth delivery
marking the beginning of the hunt for
Jon after he's declared excommunicado
the way we go with Winston saying the
line in the trailer it's a great little
nod back to mcshane's beloved portrayal
of the character Colin Woodle delivers
it brilliantly and is a great tease for
what's to come and away we go while it's
likely that the line is delivered during
an epic moment in the three-part show it
would be just as fitting as the last
line of the eagerly anticipated prequel
Story the final shot of the teaser shows
Winston and his signature attire with a
glass in hand could this be the
celebratory drink from a job well done
if so it could work just as well for
when he takes a continental as his own
the John Wick Universe might be full of
death and Mayhem but it still operates
with a code of honor for example blood
must never be spilled on Continental
grounds doing so as grounds for
immediate excommunication from The Guild
we've already seen what Jon had to go
through when he broke the rules and he's
friendly with the owner so you can
imagine how difficult it's going to be
for people who openly go to war with the
establishment the Continental trailer
shows the hotel coming under attack with
everyone from Ninjas the masked wearing
assassins showing up for the action
these killers are Rebels who don't care
about the rules and it throws everything
into chaos and disarray but who are
these people what's their agenda is the
70s version of the Continental prone to
attracting Rogue assassins or is this an
unfortunate one-off incident
at one point in the trailer a coin hits
the ground on a close-up shot Die Hard
fans of the John Wick franchise will
recognize it as an adjudicator's coin
this is a different object than the gold
coins that likewise play a pivotal role
in the franchise while a gold coin is
good for a favor from another member of
the Assassin Underworld the
adjudicator's coin is a calling card of
sorts of the adjudicator who holds an
important position at the high table the
first time the adjudicator appears is in
John Wick 3 to penalize Winston for
breaking the rules of his position and
aiding John throughout that film The
adjudicator continues to pass judgment
on those who have broken the rules of
the high table and appears to be one of
its most pivotal members as expected the
presence of the adjudicator in the
trailer seems to confirm that Cormac is
not the highest ranking criminal in the
Continental it's likely he will have to
deal at some point with those who hold
authority over him whether that means
he's in trouble with the high table or
the adjudicator becomes involved in the
show's central conflict opposite Winston
is still unclear what we learned in this
trailer that Winston Scott was not the
manager of the New York Continental
during the 1970s we now know that his
loyal friend and partner Sharon at least
held some position within the storied
establishment that being said Sharon
does not seem to be the New York
continental's concierge quite yet per
the series's IMDb page that position
will apparently be taken by Irish
musician and actor Sally Garnett also
known by her stage name Loa while we
don't get a great shot of her Concierge
in the trailer we can just barely make
out her profile when a guest presents a
coin at the front desk as for Sharon's
position it's hard to say for certain he
seems to be serving as more of a
bodyguard for Cormac presumably Dragon
Winston in and out of the building by
force I could explain why the character
shows off some impressive moves in John
Wick chapter 3.
Jerome show our guests the door when it
was first announced that Katie McGrath
would play a role called the adjudicator
in the John Wick spin-off series at
Continental some understandably assume
that she'd be playing the same character
played by Aja Kate Dylan in John wake
chapter 3. we can now all but confirm
that that's not the case this new
adjudicator wears a unique face covering
that differentiates her from any member
of the high table we've met in the
franchise so far what's more she seems
more willing to get her hands dirty than
Dylan's character did in chapter 3. the
opening scenes of the Continental
trailer show a mysterious 1969 Ford
Mustang Mach 1 which will be a familiar
sight to fans of this particular action
franchise the same car belongs to John
Wick in the movies but he won't be
behind the wheel for this outing however
the peacock series might explain why
it's so important to everyone's favorite
dog-loving mass murderer in the first
John Wick Jon tells a group of thugs
that his vehicle isn't for sale
suggesting that the car holds some
sentimental value later when the baddies
steal it Aurelio is horrified to learn
that they had the nerve to do that and
kill his dog in the process
the owner of the card did you kill him
or what
people who know Wick seem to know that
his car is important to him could that
be due to the original owner in the
Continental trailer we see a young
Winston Scott and his brother Frankie
going for a ride in the same muscle car
it even has the same license plate
decades later so there's no doubt that
it's the same car Winston is arguably
John's closest friend in the world and
four movies have proven that they have
each other's backs for the most part
considering that we're unlikely to see
John in the Continental we probably
won't see how the car made its way from
Winston's hands to John's but either way
its history with Winston is probably the
reason why John's so attached to it